With the dramatic growth in open APIs, fire adoption,
and the concept of health care app platforms,
it is tempting to speculate about the future of health information exchange.
Will specialized networks for health data sharing even be needed?
In an open standards based inter-operable Health Informatics landscape.
Many have felt for some time now that cloud based platforms,
or coordinated collaborative care,
would wrap the complex mix of underlying EHRs and
other systems into something far more useful and usable.
And some are coming from large companies with the expertise and
resources to take on hard long term problems.
Here you see a screenshot,
from the salesforce.com health cloud,
that the company announced in late 2015.
It represents a patients X terminal or
professional health care team on the right and allows them to interact with each other,
with the patient, and with the patient's internal team on the layout.
This internal team might, as shown here,
consist of family members or even professionals the patient has chosen to consult.
Earlier, I mentioned that the Veterans Administration was
a pioneer in EHR development. The V.A.
is developing a cloud based digital health platform or
DHP to create inter-operability between its Vista EHR,
the military health system,
and community based care resources that use a variety of EHRs.
Georgia Tech created a proof of concept,
showing how fire could connect the V.A.
with community based providers outside its system.
The DHP could also provide health care data analytics,
ideally in real time,
and an API for data extraction potentially creating an app platform.
At least in its pilot form,
it uses a sales force health cloud for care coordination and patient management.
Here you see a diagram of
a possible HIE architecture in a fire enabled informatics ecosystem.
The HIE concept is still present,
but it has essentially become a platform for fire apps.
This second graphic suggests an HIE architecture that is entirely API based.
These are all interesting and exciting new models for HIE.
It is possible that one of them will become the new standard.
It's equally possible that all three may find a role.
But no matter what happens,
health care seems to be heading rapidly toward
an inter-operable framework with the potential,
among other use cases,
to address the long standing need for
continuous coordinated care of the chronic diseases we discussed in lesson one.